[Music]
what does your current morning routine
look like man people love the morning
routine question over and over and over
um
so if you remember back to the early
days my morning routine was like this
minute by minute it was super regimented
and had all these different components
to it and i would explain it to people
and they would look at me like i was
insane
yeah i was um
but it had some very specific components
to it and you do this for five minutes
ago this for three minutes it was about
an hour hour and a half long and it was
just a lot
and then work got busy i started
traveling all over the country and i was
trying to take this
extensive elaborate morning routine with
me and then my kids are getting older
and
i marry all these things right and then
we moved out into the woods and i got to
deal with the chickens in the morning
all the stuff just happens
so here and
was me being honest and hopefully this
gives you some um
peace about your own life
in many ways i collapsed in on it um i
got so busy being on the road writing a
book getting it out
flying back so we could record shows and
then hitting the road again
um doing a lot of things all the same
time and
i
folded in on myself i started to sleep
in an extra 30 minutes or an extra 45
minutes or i would cheat on my workout a
little bit or i would
skip this or not so
anyway man
i i got real mortal this year um i told
somebody about may i found my limit and
it's always good to find your limit when
you're maxing out or you're doing an
all-out sprint or you've done something
stupid in your marriage or your partner
has and you find your you find the
balance there i did
so my current morning routine looks like
this
oh by the way i learn new stuff
i learn new things um i'm kind of
annoying because i'm always trying to
read and figure out new things and get
new information so here's where it is
number one here's the things that do not
under any circumstance i don't budge on
these
number one is getting sunlight in the
morning and this comes from
andrew huberman's work out of stanford
um if you don't listen his podcast um he
should it's so good um it's long and
it's in-depth and he is a neuroscience
professor at stanford in the medical
school
brilliant brilliant guy a lot of fun but
uh if you're into deep dives like how
the
neurological structures work and how the
hormones and molecular structures and
dopamine so it all works together that's
a great place to go but he's put out
some great work about the importance of
sunlight your night sleep
starts in the morning and so i don't
ever budge on that the second one is
working out movement
i still lift a lot i've gotten into
running a little bit more and the big
shift i've made is rucking r-u-c-k-i-n-g
um because of james the great james i
got a
uh goruck backpack which i love they're
not a sponsor i don't get any money off
that it's just the best there is there's
the top of the top at the top it's
expensive and it's worth every penny
and put weights in it and then head off
and so
this week i've done an hour wreck one
morning and then there's a weight
workout and then this morning i did a
long ruck so
um it's a great zone two workout the big
things i guess the big things that comes
to work out is this number one zone two
which is new i've added that in the past
year um because of peter tia's work
ultimately letting my mitochondria
rebuild let my body
rest and at the same time move um so
it's a it's a workout basically zone two
is this you're going and you can still
have a full conversation but
um
you're going right so you're getting
after it pretty good but you can still
talk
um i haven't figured how to do that on
running but i can do it on a bike i can
do it rucking and which is a really
fast-paced walk with weights on your
back basically
um
so i have to have some movement in the
morning sometimes i get 15 minutes and
that's it sometimes i get 30 minutes
usually it's 45 minutes to an hour of
something
breakfast i've i don't fast anymore um
or i do it very very infrequently um the
data on fasting has come back and we can
talk about that another show but i eat
breakfast every day now
which has been great for my energy
levels and my workout levels and all
that i do work out fasted but not for
any reason
um time with my kids and my wife i've
become much more
we may do a whole show on this one day
i've become obsessive about time
because it's a finite resource i can't
get any of it back
and i can make all the money in the
world and sell all the books in the
world and be a number one best selling
it but the time still keeps ticking it's
just tick tick tick tick and so
um i'd it's worth it to not go do some
weird aerobic yoga exercise on top of my
weight workout in the front yard when
i'm rolling around and singing songs and
chanting i'd rather this morning i
played candy lane with my daughter and
by the way i destroyed her two games in
a row she needs to learn not to step to
this but i crushed her um in candyland
but i spent some time together it was
fun we laughed talked some talk some
crap so that was cool i'm trying to
accomplish one thing in the morning work
related
and
we can talk about this later
when it comes to social media man
um
i'm trying to do one work thing just get
out of the way and sometimes that's five
minutes sometimes it's 30 minutes
sometimes it's review an article um
knock out a blog whatever it is i'm
trying to do one thing in the morning
um i've not been keeping up with my cold
tub
it's been about seven or eight maybe
nine months now um
most of that's just because i've gotten
busy and i'm doing that time with other
things i still take cold showers every
day just because i feel i don't they
feel better but
um let's talk about it i've become a
full-blown addict
100 addict i don't say this with pride
to
my my phone uh an addict addict and um
i've got my social media on one phone
and i have my life on another phone
and so i've had to start turning my
phone off and leaving it places because
i simply i can't control it and i wish i
could do something to be like i just
don't i can't i just can't
i over the last five or six months have
started
finding myself in the middle of really
remarkable events where i'm at a concert
i'm hanging out with my wife i'm doing
something with my kids and i think
this would be a really great post for
instagram
and what that does is takes me out of
the moment with my kids and it takes me
out of my moment with my wife or i've
stopped focusing on the concert and
having a good time and i start thinking
about how i'm gonna get some sort of
fake um virtue signal
look where i was look who i was with
look how cool i am because i am filling
the blank
look how whatever
and i got to stop
and so it was about a week ago i went
out of town and i forgot it i left it at
home
and it was incredible
because i was fully present and so um
i've actually invited my wife in to help
me with this but to create some really
remarkable boundaries we're leaving town
for a week probably not gonna take it
with me
and um
i just gotta create some space
full-blown attic i can't stop i sit at
home and just scroll and scroll and
scroll and type and i wanna respond and
do this
um
and i talk about all the time and it got
me and so i've got to create some robust
structures to back out of that
um so all i say about my morning routine
no more phones um before i get to work
and usually i'm leaving my social media
phone here at work if i was you and i
don't have two phones i would delete it
just delete it get rid of it get rid of
it
um gratitude journal is a thing i do all
the time and then i've added some
reading in the mornings sometimes if
it's not if i don't have a work
assignment i can crank out and then i'll
usually do some reading so that's my
morning takes about an hour and a half
to get up in the morning and get going
and get cranking
um what are my uh is that good
what's your morning routine kelly
um four four marble reds
black coffee
i ride the horse lay some bricks on the
road i'm building
and then i come to work
close to that
it's very close very close very close
now i try to get up and i usually do um
some bible reading in my prayer time you
would jesus louise you had to go there
did you
you asked
um and then it's usually run around
you've got teenagers at home it's summer
right now so luckily it's they're not
even awake before i leave but during the
school year it's getting them up and
ready and moving and then remember
remember three amigos yes
and he's like what would you do with
whatever a million dollars he's like i'd
buy all the cars and whatever and i'd
buy all this and then one guy's like i'd
build an orphanage
and to help le underprivileged children
and they're like oh yeah we do that too
so way to go kelly tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen my my morning
routine is gonna shift to uh
just some quiet time me and the bible in
my journal
and then i don't journal oh you don't no
you don't want to know what's going on
in there no no no i do i try really hard
to shove it all down i don't want to
write about it
i see every once in a while
on the show it's starting to make its
way out like nope nope nope all right
there we go morning morning routine
there we go